we prepare for the first big debate
between trump and biden
trump nominates amy coney barrett to the
supreme court democrats wail and nash
their teeth and
the new york times puts out a late hit
on trump's taxes i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
go protect it right now at
expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news of the day
and since i missed yesterday because it
was yom kippur there's plenty of news to
go over many things
happening in the world but first let us
talk about the fact that you need to be
smart
right now in this business climate you
need to save time you need to save money
you need to not go to the post office
instead you need to head on over to
stamps.com listen the post office does a
lot of great things but stamps.com
allows you to do all of those great
things without going to the post office
thousands of small business owners have
discovered the benefits of stamps.com
in recent months they've been able to
keep their businesses running and avoid
the crowds at the post office all from
their own computers with stamps.com
you can print postage on demand you can
avoid going to the post office and
you'll save money with discounted rates
that you can't even get at the post
office
stamps.com offers ups services for
example with discounts up to 62 percent
no residential surcharges we've been
using stamps.com here at dailywire since
2017 which is why we are a highly
profitable large media company
stamps.com
brings all the mailing and shipping
services you need directly to your
computer you can use
that computer to print official us
postage 24 7 any letter any package any
class email anywhere you want to send it
once your mail is ready you leave it for
the mail carrier schedule a pickup drop
it off in a mailbox it is that simple
and with stamps.com again you get those
great discounts five cents off every
stamp
up to 62 off usps and ups shipping rates
right now
my listeners get a very special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and the digital scale
no long-term commitment just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage type in shapiro
that is stamps.com
enter promo code shapiro okay so tonight
is the big first debate
huge awesome magnificent only one
problem
really there's a problem 70 percent of
americans say the debates make no
difference to them
so 30 of americans say that the debates
make some difference
to them so what do the expectations need
to be for each side
well the problem for president trump is
that trump has set the expectations so
low for biden that basically all biden
has to do
is not obviously have a needle hanging
out of his arm and stay alive those are
literally the only two things that biden
has to do
he needs to not have a complete physical
or mental collapse on the stage
and he needs to be not caught using
performance-enhancing drugs those are
the standards
that trump has set and frankly that's
kind of trump's fault one of the keys to
politics is lowering
your own expectations and heightening
expectations for the other side so what
you really should be doing in the
lead-up to a debate is talking about how
incredible
the other guy is at debate you should be
talking about how joe biden is a pro
he's been doing this for years i'm a
newbie
he's going to do amazing i think he's
really with it and then he goes in and
he disappoints when you set the
expectation at
joe biden is dead and if he is not dead
it's because he is using some sort of
cocaine
well then the standards are really
really low so that means that all biden
basically has to do
to be declared the winner is stay
somewhat coherent maybe for the first
hour of the debate because nobody is
going to watch the both hours this is
the dirty secret also
is that most people tend to tune out
over the course of the debates the first
20 minutes makes the biggest difference
in the debate
and you can expect that there will be a
lot of rock'em sock'em robots in those
moments which we'll discuss in just a
second
meanwhile the expectations for trump are
weightier right trump actually has to
somehow swivel opinion
now what he has been good at in debate
historically is tearing down his
opposition
this is what he's been best at he goes
on attack he throws the kitchen sink he
says he'll arrest hillary in open debate
if he's made president didn't happen but
i mean a boy can dream
he he suggested that he was uh that he
was going to
basically physically beat down some of
his republican opponents
in debates and you can expect that that
sort of thing will happen
from trump but the question is what can
he do that really shifts opinions about
biden and the answer is that unless
biden himself collapses
the this debate is really in biden's
hands it is not in trump's hands trump
is going to do all of the same things he
normally does
and the question is can biden handle it
can biden handle the fact
that trump is the kid you didn't want to
fight in high school not because the kid
was a great fighter but because the kid
was absolutely out of his mind
there's always one of these kids in high
school there's a kid in my high school
his name was michael
and michael was a nut okay like a
complete crazy person
and he wasn't the biggest dude he's kind
of small and wiry but if you got into a
fight with him
you never knew if he was just going to
pull out a switchblade and try to cut
off your face
right i mean that's that's trump in
debate you don't want to be in a debate
with him mainly because
he is unexpected now i think that
biden's tactic is going to be to be very
aggressive with trump at the beginning
and try and throw trump off his game i
think the trump's tactic is going to be
to be very aggressive with biden at the
very beginning and try to throw biden
off his game and i think in reality what
it's going to look like is exactly what
i've said for
literally two years at this point it's
going to be chewbacca versus the swedish
chef
it's just going to be a bunch of
nonsense that they each spout at each
other
it's going to be there's a bit smooth
so pick your fighter is it chewbacca or
the swedish chef
neri three words of english will be
spoken in this entire debate how much
intellectual policy will be discussed in
this debate almost zero
instead what you're gonna get is joe
biden implying that trump killed two
hundred thousand people of coven
and also that trump is the worst person
in the entire world and from trump
you're gonna get that joe biden is
senile
maybe on performance enhancing drugs and
corrupts right i just
saved you two hours of your time so
tonight you can watch cobra kai instead
of watching the debate and then show up
tomorrow and
sum it up all for you how do i know this
is what the debate is going to be like
because we got the preview over the
weekend so joe biden over the weekend
did an interview
in which he suggested that trump was
like joseph goebbels which is
one hell of a supposition trump is a lot
of things but comparing him to the nazis
i think probably not on that and
put aside the fact that he's the most
pro-israel president in american history
it seems like you should just
generally make a non-habit of citing
joseph goebbels as in like the nazi
propagandist
in conjunction with the president of the
united states here was joe biden doing
that over the weekend
i'm not sure anybody that hadn't already
made up their mind there for trump
believes but who knows
but that's you know he's sort of like
goebbels you say the lie long enough
keep repeating repeat and repeat it
it becomes common knowledge okay
stephanie rule tried to humor biden
through this
through this particular interview on
msnbc you can see her kind of smiling
through that wouldn't you when you think
that merits a follow-up at some point
like if you're the media member that he
compares the sitting president of the
united states to the nazi propagandist
wouldn't you think that might merit some
sort of follow-up not from msnbc
okay and then by the way how biased are
the media and this this is
going to play into the debate too
because of course chris wallace who i
think will be a good moderator
yeah he's been good in the past he's not
candy crowley i don't think he's going
to jump in
necessarily and start really shaping the
contours of the debate the way that
crowley did in 2012 when she
when she fact-checked romney and got it
absolutely wrong and by the way
apparently must have leaked to barack
obama that she had certain documentation
in her pocket i mean in the middle of
the debate in 2012 if you remember back
eight years barack obama was debating
romney and romney said a thing
and it was a true thing and obama
literally said to candy crowley
in your pocket isn't there some
documentation showing he's wrong i mean
it was pretty incredible
i don't think you're going to get that
from chris wallace however the media
spin
afterward is going to be that if biden
remains alive that he won hell in the
tank are the media for biden okay in the
middle of the stephanie rule interview
he literally gets lost in the middle of
the interview and stephanie rule starts
guiding him
out and she's like put your hand on my
shoulder
this time with my permission joe and i
will guide you out of these wilds
the paycheck protection act you know one
percent of the money's gone out
one percent one percent of the uh the
that's not the paycheck the the the um
uh
the uh the bill for small for major for
small business
okay so this is great we're gonna have
senile sam the eagle
taking on president trump's chewbacca
and that's
the angle right so biden is just gonna
call trump a liar he's gonna suggest
he's responsible for mass death from
mass carnage
and trump's response is gonna be you're
a senile old man so it'll be
entertaining is it going to change
anybody's mind
not unless one of the two candidates
does it to themselves now the good news
for trump is it's going to be very
difficult
for anybody to change the perception of
trump whatever you think about trump
you've thought about trump for a very
long time
nobody is changing their mind on trump
really the the upside for biden is that
he doesn't have to do very much
the downside for biden is that if he
doesn't do it it's going to be
devastating for him
because again all the opinions are in on
trump they're not all in on biden yet
because he's been able to ride this
thing out without doing
really any serious sort of media kamala
harris has avoided every
she has not done a single press gaggle
since she was nominated vice president
which is insane
joe biden in four of the last seven days
has called a lid meaning he's done
zero media events in four of the last
seven days that's not debate prep
that's because he understands that if he
stays away from the cameras and trump is
the center of attention then trump is in
trouble
so now trump makes biden the center of
attention and the question is can joe
stand up to it we'll get to that in just
one second first
let's talk about the fact that it's been
a very very difficult year
when's the last time somebody saw you
smile who's not a member of your
immediate family it's probably been a
while because you got a mask over that
grill
well one day you're going to remove that
mask and you want those teeth to look
good wouldn't it be a surprise for folks
if suddenly
those crooked teeth were straight and
beautiful well good news you can make
this happen right now
over at candid candid clear liners they
are comfortable removable
practically invisible unlike wire braces
so you can transform that smile without
anybody noticing plus your treatment is
prescribed and monitored remotely by a
licensed orthodontist who's an expert in
tooth movement it's all done
from the comfort and convenience of your
own home candid only works with
orthodontist never general dentists like
other companies plus
your supervising orthodontist will be
with you every step of the way with
candid your treatment includes remote
monitoring by the same orthodontist who
created your plan
so you never have to wonder how you're
doing you'll always know which i love
the average candid treatment that'll be
just six months and you'll start seeing
results way before then it costs
thousands of dollars less than braces
start straightening those teeth today
right now all my listeners can save
75 on candid starter kit go to
candidco.com
shapiro use code shapiro that is candid
c o dot com
shapiro code shapiro take advantage of
this limited time offer save 75 bucks on
your starter kit candid co.com
shapiro code shapiro go check them out
right now okay so trump for his part
says he's looking forward to the debate
now what we've been hearing over and
over is that trump didn't actually prep
for this thing
which is a huge mistake it is a big big
big mistake
because biden does have the capacity
still to memorize a couple of facts and
figures he showed this in his little cnn
interviews a little cnn town hall
he'll have a few things memorized
trump's usual
ability and debate is to stick and move
and also he really really requires a
crowd
trump is a showman he's a stand-up
comedian the crowd really helps him in
fact there will be no crowd here
means that he's not going to get a
response for him so if he says something
funny
it could obviously fall flat in any case
trump says he's looking forward to the
debate tonight
we look forward to seeing him in the
debate he's got a lot more experience
he's got 47 years i've got three and a
half years
so wilson he's got 47 years of
experience
you know i always sort of smile when he
said like criticism we should have done
this we should have done that we should
all these things right i said why didn't
you do him
he's been there for and it's not like he
left 20 years ago
47 years and he left three and a half
years ago right
so why the hell didn't you do him now he
went it's all these great ideas that's a
real beauty
okay so this actually is a really good
angle for trump the problem as
always with the trump campaign is that
the message is split if his message had
been
for months that biden's been there for
47 years he did none of the things he
was talking about doing he's been
incompetent every step of the way the
only reason that he's famous is because
barack obama plucked him
from presidential failure and obscurity
and decided to make him vp specifically
because he was kind of the go along to
get along chummy fellow from the senate
that's a good angle the problem is that
trump splits his message as always
so over the weekend trump also said that
biden was taking performance enhancing
drugs again that lowers expectations
because once you say that biden is
taking performance enhancing drugs
basically unless the man keels over on
the stage completely
people are just going to declare that he
surpassed expectations
if you look at some of those debates i
said there's no way he can continue he
can't continue
then all of a sudden he debated crazy
bernie sanders and you know what the
truth is he was
he was okay and i said how did he go
from there
with those horrible performances to
where he was
okay and i always joke but you know it
is true he was no winston churchill
in debating but he was fine and
people say he was on performance
enhancing drugs a lot of people have
said that a lot of people have written
that
this morning rudy giuliani went on fox
and friends and suggested that biden was
on adderall
okay here's the thing if biden does well
enough that you have to suggest that
he's on performance enhancing drugs
you lose because there is no drug
testing plus the idea of joe biden on
serious performance enhancing drugs
he's taking the steroids i mean it will
all this will be amusing
i mean it'll be good tv right let's say
the biden is doing well halfway through
and trump's like why don't you take a
drug test joe are and using the cream
and the clear and the clearing the cream
and mine's like how's your jam
what's happening well i mean again good
tv
no one's gonna know what the hell is
going on tonight so watch it for the
entertainment value
unless there is some sort of epic biden
collapse i don't think it's gonna make
much of a difference because it's hard
to change opinions about trump it's
not super easy to change opinions about
biden because the expectations have been
so wildly lowered okay with all of that
said the two big topics that will
certainly come up tonight
are amy coney barrett the presidential
nominee to fill the rbg seat which
that'll be a good topic for trump a very
good topic for trump especially because
joe biden has been attempting to avoid
all responsibility for talking about
packing the court
and trump's taxes that will come up
because the media decided to lay out a
hit on trump two days before the debate
it seemed pretty obvious given how
quickly the biden campaign started
turning around ads that they had some
sort of prior knowledge of this but in
any case we'll get to that in one second
first
let us talk about the fact that there
are cases we are seeing them every day
now
where there is somebody who has to use a
gun in self-defense and then the cops
come and arrest the person who had to
use the gun
in self-defense and frankly that's not
the cops fault i mean very often
local regulations mean that they have to
pick the person up here's the bottom
line you have to know your rights you
have to know how to use a gun in
self-defense
you have to not only be able to protect
yourself but also comply
with the law and this is why you need
the help of the folks over at the u.s
concealed carry association
right now you can take a simple and
powerful journey to firearms and
self-defense
confidence it's called the complete
concealed carry and family defense guide
from the uscca it is 100
free you'll learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting the safest and
most dangerous places to sit in a
restaurant how to responsibly own and
store a gun even if you have little kids
and a whole lot more it's 164 pages
it comes with a bonus audio version so
you can listen whenever you want just
text ben
to 87 222 you'll get instant access and
a chance to win a thousand bucks so you
can buy a gun to protect your family
today
text ben 287 222 i own firearms
i wanna be able to protect my family and
i wanna know how to use them properly
and that is why i trust the uscca
you should too when you go register with
them by texting ben to 87222
you get a free copy of the complete
concealed carry and family defense guide
go check them out right now text ben to
222. okay so the two two of the big
topics that are going to come up tonight
obviously covet is going to come up
tonight
and trump is going to have to defend his
covet record and
when it comes to covid trump's case
basically should be
that he gave all the states exactly what
they needed
that biden has not made a single
proposal that is different from anything
trump has already said that biden was
holding rallies into early march
and all of the rest and that right now
trump is intent on opening up the
country while biden has said he will
shut it back down
so i think trump can defend himself on
the coveted stuff the big problem for
trump
is that biden is going to come at him
and say you were purposely down playing
it to the american public you said you
were down playing it
trump has said that he was both down
playing it and now playing it biden's
theme tonight is that trump is dishonest
and trump's theme tonight is going to be
the biden is senile and incompetent
those are going to be
the the themes of the evening okay so
let's take those themes to the to the
two key topics that are not coveted
related tonight one is the filling
of the seat held most lately by ruth
bader ginsburg i hesitate to call it
rbgc because it is not rbg's seat it is
nobody's seat it is a supreme court seat
that was filled by rbg just like it is
not trump's oval office it is the oval
office and trump occupies it
that seat does not belong to ruth bear
ginsburg which is why it's so
unbelievably silly
when you hear these ridiculous people
suggesting
that rbg's dying wish is ought to be
honored and that her seat ought to be
filled by somebody that she selects this
is something chuck schumer continues to
push
push over the weekend judge ginsburg had
a dying wish
that the next president choose as the
american people
learn of judge barrett's views they're
going she is going to become very
unpopular with average americans
and as that unpopularity rises i hope
they will put pressure
on their republican senators to adhere
to justice ginberg's dying wish
and let the next president decide there
is no dying wish provision in the
constitution of the united states as my
friend bridges fedex has said
filling a supreme court seat is not a
make-a-wish foundation kind of thing
you don't get to decide exactly how that
seat is going to be filled that is not
how any of this works
it's a very stupid point that people
continue to press forward as though this
is quote unquote rbgc it is not
rbgc in the same sense that again the
oval office is not trump's office that's
not the way
any of that works okay but the democrats
continue to push forward
against amy coney barrett the problem is
that amy coney barrett happens to be a
fantastic nominee
and people from both sides of the aisle
know that she's a fantastic nominee noah
feldman who teaches at harvard law
school
and is very much on the left you'll
remember that no feldman testified
on behalf of the impeachment inquiry
into president trump suggesting that he
should in fact be impeached over his
activities with regard to ukraine he
came out he wrote a column he said she's
very well qualified for the supreme
court there are a bunch of folks left
right and center who've come out and
said that she is qualified for the
supreme court so over the weekend trump
did what he does best he provided a very
good event in which he introduced amy
coney barrett here was what amy coney
barrett had to say
i am so grateful to you and the first
lady to the vice president and the
second lady
and to so many others here for your
kindness
on this rather overwhelming occasion
i fully understand that this is a
momentous decision
for a president and if the senate does
me the honor of confirming me
i pledge to discharge the
responsibilities of this job to the very
best of my ability
i love the united states and i love the
united states constitution
okay she continued along these lines and
she pointed out her own political
philosophy
she said judges are not policymakers it
is their job to interpret the law is not
to make the law which
of course is the key to both textualism
and originalism judges are a different
body
than the legislature this is why she is
a good nominee and a good judge
i clerked for justice scalia more than
20 years ago
but the lessons i learned still resonate
his judicial philosophy is mine too
a judge must apply the law as written
judges are not policy makers and they
must be resolute and setting
aside any policy views they might hold
okay again this is the key to to a good
judge
under any circumstances a judge's job is
to interpret the law it is not to make
the law so they know that they can't
attack her on her basic
her basic judicial philosophy because
it's the same philosophy that animates
thomas
and scalia and alito and there are
variations within that sort of
rubric but those variations are fairly
well established
so instead they've decided to go after
amy coney baird on a personal level so
amy coney bear has seven children two of
them are adopted and are from haiti
she is by all accounts an excellent
mother she certainly is not a subjugated
woman she's being nominated for the
supreme court here is amy coney barrett
explaining that her children are her
greatest joy
our children obviously make our life
very full
while i am a judge i'm better known back
home as a room parent
carpool driver and birthday party
planner
when schools went remote last spring i
tried on another hat
jessie and i became co-principals of the
barrett e-learning academy
and yes the list of enrolled students
was a very long one
our children are my greatest joy even
though they deprive me of any reasonable
amount of sleep
so the the good news about amy coney
bear's nomination is not just that she
will be a very good justice in my
opinion but also
that she is just a magnet for the hatred
of the left it's insane you knew it was
coming right because she's a religious
catholic and because she has seven kids
including two adopted from haiti
you knew the left was gonna lose their
mind over the fact that this is a
religious person
because the dirty little secret is for
many on the left people who are
religious are evil
people who are religious are benighted
morons who cannot be let near the levers
of power
anybody who is religious is a theocrat
by nature it cannot be
that you're a religious person who
believes in these strictures of the
american constitution that you believe
in a
very solid and very rich social fabric
that exists outside of government but
you believe the government's job is not
to intervene in the lives of americans
you can't believe that
if you're a religious person you must be
a simpleton expressing this view most
clearly
was the creator of religious and
extraordinarily simplistic
documentary on the stupidity of religion
here was bill maher over the weekend
calling amy coney barrett
an effing nut okay now you just saw her
does she sound like a nut to you again
this is a woman who taught law at
university of notre dame she clerked for
justice scalia
she's been on the 7th circuit court of
appeals does she sound like a nut to you
like really but here is here is mar
because she's religious she's a nut
that's the way this works
but apparently the pick is going to be
this omi
omi amy comey will all be saying this
name a lot i'm sure because she's a
nut religion
i was right about that one too amy
sorry but amy
comey barrett catholic really catholic i
mean
really really catholic like speaking in
tongues
like she doesn't believe in condoms
which is what she has in common with
trump because he doesn't either
okay so um just just a quick point um i
believe that the
the speaking in tongues thing i'm pretty
sure that that actually is pentecostals
am i am i right about that
i don't believe that that has anything
to do with catholicism but in any case
bill maher you know this this is the
attack right the line of attack on amy
coney bear is that she is too religious
and she's very very bad in order to
promulgate that attack all they have to
do is just ignore all the facts about
amy coney barrett
so there's a piece in new york in the
new yorker today
by jeffrey toobin suggesting that she is
going to be an anti-abortion extremist
because
she is religious the only reason that
she's being nominated is because she
wants to get rid of abortion because
she's in fact a catholic nut job
and this is the the basic idea here now
let's be clear about this
roe versus weight is a terrible case
there are people left right and centered
who acknowledge the roe vs wade is a
poorly reasoned decision that has
nothing to do with the constitution of
the united states the truth is roe
versus wade is not going to be
overturned by amy coney bear or nearly
anybody else
instead they may pair back at planned
parenthood versus casey which is the
undue burden standard which is again a
very very silly standard
but in any case the anti-religious
nature
of what's going on right now is very
clear to everyone and that is a good
thing for trump politically speaking
because there are a lot of catholics in
michigan there are a lot of catholics in
pennsylvania there are a lot of
catholics in wisconsin
those are three fairly heavily catholic
states and he needs
at least one of those three states right
now right now if i'm looking at the
polling data
in these various battleground states
trump is basically running dead even
inside the margin of error with biden
in florida and he is running about five
points down in pennsylvania michigan and
wisconsin
according to the latest polling averages
he's running about even in north
carolina and he's running slightly down
in arizona in order for trump to
replicate the map he needs to win
arizona and then he needs to pick up one
of those other three states
the attacks on religion that are being
levied by the democrats against amy
coney barrett
could be helpful in that and the media
are falling right into the trap
so that is a good political news for
trump we'll get to that in just one
second first
let's talk about the fact that you need
to encrypt your data there are many
reasons to encrypt your data when you're
online
one there are hackers who are looking
for that data they're gonna make money
off of it too
isps gather that data and then they
monetize that data off of your back it
belongs to you why should you just hand
that data
to isps who may not agree with you
ideologically and who may use that data
to target you in malicious ways or make
it hack themselves this is why i use
expressvpn to stay secure online
it's hard to know whether your device or
network is vulnerable if you ever use
wi-fi at a hotel or shopping mall you're
sending data over an open network that
means no encryption at all the best way
to ensure all your data is encrypted and
can't be read by hackers is to use
expressvpn
just download the expressvpn app on your
computer or smartphone tap one button
secure 100 of your network data and then
use the internet the way you normally
would expressvpn is incredibly reliable
it's the fastest vpn service i've tried
they're also rated the world's number
one
vpn provider by review sites like
techradar and cnet if you want the best
in online security and privacy
protection head on over to
expressvpn.com
ben for three extra months free with a
one year package protect your internet
today with the vpn i trust to keep my
data safe go to expressvpn.com to get
started i use expressvpn
you should too expressvpn.com
to get started okay so the attacks on
amy coney barrett
have come from basically a couple angles
and they're both personal
one is the religious angle so you've
seen the associated press
run a ridiculous story targeting a group
to which barrett belongs
called people of praise people of praise
is basically just a religious
get-together group by the way it's not
ecumenical meaning that it is not a
purely catholic group
the ap ran a long story about the evils
of
the of this people of praise group and
they used specifically
the descriptions of a woman named coral
anika theo to talk about how evil this
group was
there's only one problem according kevin
daly over at the federalist
this woman has a track record of
hyper-partisan online posting
far-fetched lawsuits and fantastic
grievance peddling
that cast doubt on her credibility a
review of this woman's writings and
again she was used as the chief source
in the attacks against people of praise
a review of her writings litigation
history and social media footprint
shows theo has accused her own children
her parents were therapists and her
attorneys of abuse and neglect while
waging a quixotic
legal crusade against them since the
late 1990s her ex-husband
von martin warner obtained a defamation
judgment against her in 2014.
so once again the media jumped on the
story which is the people of praise is
evil and terrible
and also suggested things that are just
patently false about people of praise
which again is just
basically a social group for catholics
and some protestants to get together and
try to do good in their community
there are a couple of things where
they've jumped specifically on them one
is
that women call themselves handmaids in
this group until a couple of years ago
when the handmaid's tale became like a
big cultural phenomenon
the reason they were called handmaids is
not because in fact they were involved
in some sort of bizarre sex cult allah
the handmaid's tale it's because
in the new testament mary is described
as a handmaiden for god
right so the idea was that women are
supposed to be handmaidens for god in
the catholic view
so that is fairly uncontroversial also
apparently it is deeply controversial
to say that men ought to be the head of
their household because biblically
speaking
it talks about a man being the head of
the household now for those who are
non-religious let me explain
when it says that a man is the head of a
household so in judaism
the head of the household the man is
called the baal habit right which
literally means the master of the house
that doesn't mean
that the master of the house is the
unparalleled ruler of the household in
fact if you read the bible what you'll
see is that women are very often in
control of the household sarah
is much more in control of the household
than abraham ever is
okay all it means that you're the master
of the household is that you are held
responsible for what happens in the
household
that's all that means okay it doesn't
mean that every single decision that
gets made is made without the input of
your wife
first of all any husband who does that
will be divorced within five minutes or
we'll be in a deeply unhappy marriage
but for non-religious people they see
master of the house and they think oh
well that means that he's enslaving his
wife and he's enslaving his children and
they're his property
no it means that you are held
responsible for what happens in your
household and as the person held
responsible that means you have a higher
degree of responsibility for what
happens inside your household
end of story that's all that means it
also means that in issues of justice
with kids typically men tend to be the
court of final appeal
which every single human being knows
right if you've ever lived in a
household with a father and a mother
they hold very different role roles in
the household generally speaking
and not true in every single case but on
average the disciplinarian in the house
is dead
because he's got a teenage boy who's 13
years old and he's making trouble and
mom gets mad
guess what a 13 year old boy does
unfortunately they typically laugh
and then mom says wait till dad gets
home so when the bible talks about the
head of the household being a man
it doesn't mean women are disregarded or
ought to be regarded and all of this
in pursuit of a narrative that amy coney
barrett is pregnant and in the kitchen
she's literally on the seventh circuit
court of appeals and now is going to be
on the supreme court of the united
states so i don't know how you even
square that circle but
democrats will do their best the other
angle that i saw emerging over the
weekend and this one is just insane i
think democrats will be smart enough to
stay away from this
but not the radicals in their own party
so ibra max kenny who's just a
disgusting human being i mean ibrahmax
kennedy's view of anti-racism which i've
talked about extensively on the program
is itself racist as well as fascist this
is a person who has openly proposed
creating inside the executive branch of
the united states
a department of anti-racism tasked with
striking down
any law in the united states local state
or federal that
has a disparate impact on people meaning
that if
a law has a a different impact on black
people than white people
not because it is intended to have a
different impact or because it is
directed to black people and white
people differently
but because people act differently in
particular groups
then that will be declared racist and
this fascist department will have the
power to strike it down and simply
rewrite the law without being elected
right i mean this department of
anti-racism is not subject to outside
pressures
that is the view of ibrahim kennedy
who's an idiot okay but he's a
very successful idiot he's made an
extraordinary con out of this i mean the
guy writes for the atlantic and he
has gotten a 10 million dollar donation
from jack dorsey over at twitter
here's what he tweeted out
after jenny beth martin of tea party usa
or f of uh the tea party generally uh
jenny beth martin
tweeted out about amy coney barrett
about her kids and she pointed out that
amy coney barrett
has two adopted children from haiti
here's what ibrahim kendi tweeted out
and this is just morally benighted quote
some white colonizers adopted
black children scare quotes around
adopted they civilized again
scare quotes these scare-quoted savage
children in the quote-unquote superior
ways of white people
while using them as props in their
life-long pictures of denial while
cutting the biological parents of these
children out of the picture of humanity
okay so let's just be clear the response
to amy coney barrett
is not a racist she has two adopted
black children is some
white racist used to adopt black
children and then civilize these quote
unquote savage
children and then use them as props
so the only reason you say that is
because you're implying that maybe that
is exactly what
amy coney baird is doing without
evidence that she adopted
two kids who needed parents from a
greatly impoverished country and abram
kennedy's take is
well she's a white lady who's adopting
black kids that means she's using them
as props
and she then he adds and whether this is
barrett or not is not the point it's a
belief too many white people have if
they have or adopt a child of color
they can't be racist i'm challenging the
idea that white parents of kids of color
are inherently not racist
and the bots completely change what i'm
saying to white parents of kids of color
are inherently racist
these live and fake bots are good at
their propaganda let's not argue with
them
see whenever you get owned on twitter
your typical response on the left is
it's russian bots it's not russian bots
that you're an idiot and you're a
morally benighted idiot at that
if you want to read more deeply about
cross-racial adoption randall kennedy
professor at harvard law school has
written
several books about cross-racial
adoption and the immense good that can
be done when people
adopt people as individuals as opposed
to as quote unquote members of their
race
okay it doesn't mean ignoring the racial
divisions that exist
it doesn't mean ignoring the racial
background of the child who are adopting
but everyone kenny's
just gross just grows so more of this
please if you're on the right more of
this right more
the the reason that trump put up amy
coney barrett is specifically to act as
a magnet
for this sort of bat bleepery from the
left and so far
it seems to be doing the job meanwhile
joe biden should be asked questions
about amy clooneybar tonight
he should be forced to call her a
theocrat which would be interesting
because he is a catholic himself
supposedly and when i say supposedly i
mean that he's been denied communion
by at least one church for his
pro-abortions position his pro-abortion
positions
uh biden also should be asked
specifically about
packing the court so biden's entire
campaign thus far has been run
on the premise that he's never going to
have to ask a tough answer a tough
question
and except for the base he probably
won't by the way
breaking news apparently joe biden asked
for and was refused
a half hour break every half hour for
the entire debate tonight
which does not speak well to uh his
health actually and if you're asking but
like on the half hour
i mean this show this podcast is
normally an hour
if i had to get up like every single
half hour that would not speak
extraordinarily well of of my health
apparently the trump campaign also
wanted the biden campaign to allow a
third party to inspect the ears of the
debaters for electronic devices or
transmitters
apparently trump consensus the
inspection that biden had not
at that point as of this point at all in
any case
biden has been dodging serious questions
about court packing and he will openly
say the reason i'm dodging these
questions is because i want the focus to
remain on trump here was joe biden
dodging it again over the weekend
[Music]
to the us supreme court but what should
be the consequences for republicans if
they force judge barrett's nomination
through
and confirm they should see to it that
the american public will
vote on the senate races in this
election
and they'll vote republicans out of
office that's the consequence
okay so again the fact that he won't
answer the question about court packing
is pretty telling commonwealth harris
wouldn't either the reason being
the true answer this should be pretty
easy elect democrats and then when
a vacancy is open then we'll fill it but
instead they don't want to deny
the crazies in their base all of the
passion so instead they suggest that if
you elect them they will solve all
problems and the way to solve problems
is to break the constitutional structure
entirely here's kamala harris deflecting
when asked about court packing
if uh judge barrett is confirmed and
the democrats have control of the senate
next year and the white house and the
house representatives
should the supreme court be expanded
uh you know what let's i think that
first of all joe's been very clear
that um he is going to to
pay attention to the fact and i'm with
him on this one thousand percent
pay attention to the fact that right now
lawrence people are
voting okay that that is
okay at some point they're going to have
to answer this question would you
fundamentally break
institutions of government it's amazing
that they've been able to escape a
follow-up on that sort of stuff
for at this point weeks weeks maybe
months
and by the way if these are the geniuses
who are going to run our government
they're going to fix everything it would
behoove people like kamala harris not to
screw up
the uh the distinction between notorious
rbg
ruth bader ginsburg and the notorious
b.i.g you know the uh the rapper
even i knew that one kamala she was part
of our culture yes
we wear those notorious b.i.g t-shirts
with a lot of pride those are notorious
big t-shirts i don't think they say the
same thing as the notorious rbg
t-shirts just gonna put that out there
okay in just a second we'll get to the
other topic that will come up
at tonight's debate i am sure at length
and that is president trump's taxes and
the new york times dropping a supposed
bombshell that really is not a bombshell
on trump we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about the fact
that this election is pretty darn
important it really is and as we will
discuss in just a few moments
democrats are using every avenue at
their disposal in order to get out the
vote that
includes ballot harvesting it includes
pretty much
everything you can imagine it includes
khloe kardashian putting out
sort of thirst traps for people to
register to vote if you're as long as
you're a democrat we'll get to that in a
little bit
but because this is an important
election it actually is kind of
important that you get involved
and that's a question i get all the time
i listen to the show i'm really involved
like i i love this stuff i'm interested
in this stuff i understand the fate of
the country
is a steak what do i do the answer is
you need to go to keepamericamerica.com
right now voting has already started in
some states it's about to start with
others if you live in ohio
early in-person voting begins 28 days
before the election in arizona it's 27
days
before the election go to
keepamericamerica.com right now they'll
get you the most trusted up-to-date
voting information while you're there
please commit to take one person to the
polls that's just one or help them
complete a mail-in ballot
the 2016 election was decided by
thousands of votes
not millions and 300 000 of you across
the country have already gone
to keepamericamerica.com i personally
would love to see that number reach a
million i know they would too
do a little do a lot go to
keepamericamerica.com right now again
that's keepamericaamerica.com
go check them out right now and get
involved keepamerica america.com
okay we'll get to trump's taxes and the
bombshell that really isn't
in just one second but first in case you
missed it we had another great episode
of the sunday special this last weekend
former trump administration press
secretary
sarah huckabee sanders joined me to
discuss her time working for the
president
her best and worst days as press
secretary which reporters are the worst
off camera
i think you might know the answer and
the real questions we need more
teleprompter trump go watch over at
dailywire.com listen on apple podcast
spotify or wherever else
you get your podcast also tonight it's
fight night are you ready to watch
chewbacca
versus the swedish chef her demands
beard demanding birds are you ready
tonight 9 pm eastern 6 p.m pacific
donald trump and joe biden
face off in the first of three
presidential debates this election
season
will joe biden physically fall asleep
will donald trump
wear a mask of hillary's face join us
for an all-new episode of daily wire
backstage to watch the debate with us
get our immediate live reaction to this
major
political event and even better join
daily wire right now as an insider or
all-access member get 20
with code debate 20 off you can watch
all the debate coverage live on our
apple tv or roku app
our coverage will start 15 minutes
before the debate at 8 45 pm eastern 5
45 pm pacifica join us then
also our members get our articles ad
free access to all of our live
broadcasts and show library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show exclusive reader's past content
available only to daily wire members if
you're considering an all-access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every night for online and
live stream discussions you also get not
one but two
leftist years tumblr with your
membership as well as early sometimes
exclusive access to new daily wire
products so
watch the debate with us tonight on
dailywire.com youtube facebook
suffer with us through this debate get
20 off your daily wire membership with
code debate
when you sign up today you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
alrighty so the other big topic that i'm
sure will come up tonight
is obviously this new york times report
on president trump's taxes so first
things first
if somebody actually leaked proprietary
information on trump's taxes from like
the irs
to the uh to the new york times that's
illegal
uh that that should be somewhat
disturbing to all of us now i've been a
proponent for a long time that trump
should have released his tax returns in
2016 and then certainly after he was
president he should have just released
his tax returns like what the hell was
the downside of just releasing
the tax returns i'm also not of the
opinion that this is going to be an
entirely
damage-free scenario for trump because
what they report is that trump in the
last couple of years
has paid like a combined 1500 bucks in
federal taxes
and the natural reaction of people is
not a logical one
namely that our system itself is screwed
up that our deduction system is really
messed up in this country that we should
basically just have a flat tax in this
country and we should get rid of all of
the deductions
entirely instead of that people react
with well he's a rich guy why isn't he
paying lots of taxes okay the answer is
that over the years he's i'm sure
paid many many many taxes also it is
true that he has not done anything
illegal
so normally in a situation like this
you'd have to ask yourself okay so what
did trump do wrong
so there are a few accusations as to
what trump could have done wrong here
one he did something illegal on his
taxes like tax fraud
presumably the irs would be all over
that too he could have obtained
some sort of nefarious financial aid
from some affair i guess foreign players
there's no evidence
of that or three you somehow think that
just because you're rich
you should be giving more money to the
government than you're actually legally
obligated to do which is idiotic and
even joe biden doesn't do that as it
turns out
joe biden has been spending years
dodging the payroll tax
i mean in august the wall street journal
reported
that the the bidens dodged the payroll
tax they used an s corp to avoid paying
more than half a million dollars in
levies for medicare and obamacare
as well apparently both he and jill went
out of their way to avoid funding
seniors entitlement benefits according
to their tax returns in 2017 and 2018
the bidens and his wife jill avoided
payroll taxes
on nearly 13.3 million dollars in income
from book royalties and speaking fees
they did so by classifying the income as
s
corp profits rather than taxable wages
the bidens did pay themselves
salaries from their corporations of
nearly 750 000 between them
over two years they paid full taxes on
that income but they circumvented the
payroll tax on the nearly 95
of that income that remained a tax
expert interviewed by the journal in
2019 called the biden schema pretty
aggressive
another told the paper it served solely
to avoid the payroll taxes
of the taxes the bidens avoided 2.9
percent of their income about 385
thousand dollars would have funded
medicare the other 0.9 percent
nearly 120 000 was part of obamacare and
fund that law so here's the rule
did they do anything illegal no did
trump do anything illegal no
if you don't like the tax code good idea
you can restructure it also
if you're complaining about the fact
that that president trump didn't pay
enough tax
you should also point out that trump
lowered taxes for everyone
specifically more so on the bottom end
of the scale
okay in sheer absolute numbers whenever
there's a tax cut people at the top
make the most money because people at
the top had the most money to make
but in terms of the disproportionate
benefit of the taxes
it really hit people lower down on the
on the income scale more than it hit
people higher up on the income scale
if you're not just talking like sure
absolute numbers if you're talking about
percentage decreases or if you are
talking
about the benefits that are received
under the tax bill people like me living
in california
i actually got shellacked by the trump
tax cuts because it got rid of the state
and local tax deductions
so that meant that i had to pay both my
state and federal taxes one on top of
the other as opposed to taking the state
taxes in california
and taking them against the federal
taxes in any case what exactly is the
bombshell here so the new york times
reports that donald trump paid 75
50 total 750 in federal income taxes the
year he won the presidency in his first
year in the white house he paid another
period not 750 thousand 750 bucks
like the cost of you know a couple of
car payments he had paid no income taxes
at all
in 10 of the previous 15 years largely
because he reported losing much more
money than he made
according to the new york times as the
president wages a re-election campaign
that polls say he's in danger of losing
his finances are under stress beset by
losses and hundreds of millions of
dollars in debt coming due
that he has personally guaranteed also
hanging over him is a decade-long audit
battle with the irs
over the legitimacy of a 72.9 million
tax refund he claimed and received
after declaring huge losses an adverse
ruling could cost him more than 100
million dollars
the tax returns that trump has long
fought to keep private tell a
story fundamentally different from the
one he has sold to the american public
his reports to the irs portray a
businessman who takes in hundreds of
millions of dollars a year yet racks up
chronic losses that he aggressively
employs to avoid paying taxes now with
financial challenges mounting the
records show he depends more and more on
making money from businesses that put
him in potential
and often direct conflict of interest
with his job as president
so somehow the new york times obtained
tax return data extending more than two
decades for trump
and the hundreds of companies that make
up his business again this is probably a
legal violation
in some way trump for his part called
them fake news
he said i have paid taxes he said i've
litigated this before you can't
simultaneously say that they are fake
news and also that you have
and and also that you're smart for
avoiding taxes which is something that
he has said
in the past the new york times dean
paquette put out a full note talking
about why they put this out and the
answer is because they hate donald trump
and they say we're not making the
records themselves public because we do
not want to jeopardize our sources who
have taken enormous personal risks to
help inform the public
we are publishing this report because we
believe citizens should understand as
much as possible about their leaders and
representatives their priorities their
experiences
and also their finances so in other
words we are it's not a violation of law
for the new york times to do this
just a note the new york times was a lot
more
divided in nature about publishing the
wikileaks stuff which again
i think there's a case we made we
shouldn't publish the wikileaks stuff
then they then they have been about
publishing trump's taxes
the the basic idea here is threefold
from democrats one
trump is not the successful businessman
he says he is which
i mean okay sure
also whatever you think about how trump
has handled his businesses he has not
used
public office in order to enrich himself
joe biden was worth no money then he was
vice president now he's worth tens of
millions of dollars
barack obama had the same deal like his
net worth when he when he entered office
was like a million bucks or something
and now barack obama's probably worth
nine figures he's probably 100 million
dollars now it turns out that people who
make money after being in public office
pose significantly more of a threat to
the institutional architecture of the
republic than people who had a lot of
money going in
i've always been bewildered by the idea
that if you were rich before you went in
somehow this is a demerit
it seems like that should actually be a
merit but it is true that part of
trump's pitch for a long time has been
that he is world breaking business
genius
and i've doubted that story for a very
long time i've always said i'm not even
sure that he's worth a billion dollars
that doesn't mean that he's poor but it
doesn't mean that he is not the great
businessman
he said he was okay that's a hit but
it's not much of one
the other hit is supposedly that trump
is dodging
taxes okay and again there's no evidence
of this the new york times itself
says there is no evidence either that
trump has dodged taxes or has violated
the law
or that he's in hawks of the ruski's and
yet those are all narratives that
democrats are trying to throw out there
today so first of all as far as paying
no taxes that actually is not breaking
news
all the way back in 2016 hillary clinton
suggested that trump paid no taxes and
trump said
in open debate right i didn't pay taxes
because i'm smart not stupid
maybe he doesn't want the american
people all of you watching tonight
to know that he's paid nothing in
federal taxes because the only years
that anybody's ever seen were a couple
of years when he had to turn them over
to state authorities when he was trying
to get a casino license and they
showed he didn't pay any federal income
tax
so that makes me smart zero
okay so he said that makes me far
smarter right he he comes back he's
making me far smarter than anybody else
okay again it's not like this is a big
secret everybody has sort of speculated
about this for a very long time
and the new york times shows no evidence
of legality that doesn't stop carl
bernstein worse than watergate carl
bernstein
carl bernstein has spent his entire
career just saying worse than watergate
ever since watergate so this is worse
than watergate
too ukraine was worse than watergate
trump talking about the election was
worse than watergate everything is worse
than watergate for carl bernstein
this is really the smoking gun of a
pervasively
criminal presidency we have a president
of the united states
who is a grifter his family are grifters
and this is the definitive evidence of
it this once again
points to the president's foreign
entanglements
for his own political purposes and his
own financial good
there are certainly implications of tax
fraud to be
to begin with that needs to be looked at
and will be looked at
remember that one time he reported a
story and it was like 15 years before i
was born and we're gonna pretend like
he's still a relevant figure carl
bernstein
okay so that story's done the idea that
he did anything illegal if he did
we have an entire wing of the federal
government that is designed to go after
people
who violate tax law okay the second
attack
is that he is in hawk to the ruski's
there's no evidence he's in hot to the
ruskies in fact it says directly in many
of the documents i think it's page 35 of
his disclosures
federal disclosures who he owes money to
that didn't stop kamala harris from
doing the
who do you owe money to president trump
here is kamala harris
who does he owe the money to tell us who
do you owe the money to
and um do you owe debt to any foreign
nation do you who you know do you owe
debt do you owe money let's just be
clear about what debt means you owe
somebody money
do you owe anybody money who is impacted
by any decision you make as president of
the united states
we need to know that okay again there's
no evidence that he
is being in any way twisted around by
foreign adversaries remember
they tried they've been trying this crap
since 2016. and they're not going to
stop
nancy pelosi then suggested that trump's
debt is a national security question
what does putin have on him what does
they never change the tune
i mean guys stick and move a little bit
nancy pelosi the adult nancy pelosi
continuing to suggest that this is all
about what putin does all roads lead to
putin is nancy pelosi's routine
it's just it's absurd this is absurd you
guys are making mockeries of yourself
this president appears to have over 400
million dollars in debt 420 whatever it
is
million dollars in debt to whom
different countries what is the leverage
they have so for me
this is a national security question
the question is what does putin have on
the president politically
personally financially in every way that
the president would try to undermine our
commitment to nato
okay this is just i'm sorry this is so
tiring this kind of crap is so tight and
then
msnbc has on the greatest of all
political analysts a person who once
played a politician on tv
you know we're now beyond the point of
parity
i mean do you remember there was a
commercial back in the 1970s
in which a guy who played a doctor on
general hospital led off the commercial
by saying
i'm not a doctor but i play one on tv
okay well now you got jeff daniels
who was not in fact a newsman but played
one on tv now he's talking about his
theories about trump's taxes
because we need to hear from jeff
daniels okay here's jeff daniels on that
great news network
msnbc what are they talking about in
helsinki
what were you know all the stuff i mean
there's all of that the tax returns that
he won't show us
it's so obvious and where is he getting
the money where did he get all the money
and and i mean all roads as
speaker pelosi said all roads lead to
putin and
you know time's running out this is a
bad movie we're living through that's
what this
is he should know bad movies i mean
honest to god he really should but
that is that is very solid stuff right
there from jeff daniels definitely
needed to hear from
from that guy from the dumb and dumber
guy i need to hear from him right now
get him on the line stat we need to hear
from jeff daniels right now stat
on trump's taxes okay the final angle of
course is that trump is poorer than he
said he is and that's really bad
again do i think it looks good for trump
to pay 750 bucks in taxes over the last
couple years
no i i don't but would it matter they
went after mitt romney and said that
mitt romney didn't pay his taxes he paid
effective tax rate harry reid just lied
about it is any of this going to make a
serious done for trump
probably not is it going to come up
tonight probably but again
do i think it's that the media are going
to gog over this thing and i'm just like
why you don't have enough material
against trump you got to go to this
seriously okay meanwhile in other news
uh president trump has been saying for a
while here that he is deeply
concerned about voter fraud and about
the possibility of voter fraud
well now project veritas has released
some videos alleging widespread voter
fraud
in minneapolis they are blaming
representative ilhan omar they're
suggesting
that she is to blame for some of this uh
they apparently got a hold of a person
who was involved in ilhan omar's get out
the vote effort
and the suggestion is that they have
basically been paying people for their
votes
according to twincities.com the pioneer
press a report
by the non-profit a report by the
nonprofit
suggests that the mishandling of
absentee ballots in minnesota in
minneapolis's somali community
is is now making news and it and it
should
here's a little bit of the video from
project veritas again this is being
now checked into apparently by the state
authorities in minnesota so we will see
how much there is to it although it's
run by keith ellison so i have my
suspicions as to what the
findings will be in any case here is uh
the project veritas video
all these secure absolutely the person
speaking somali can't you see look at
these my car is full
my car is full
well all of these are for jamal
just today we got 300 ballots for jamal
osman a source said they
how is that working they've perfected
this system miranda devine reports for
the new york post a ballot harvesting
racket in democratic representative
ilhano mars minneapolis district where
paid workers illegally gather
absentee ballots from elderly somali
immigrants appears to have been busted
by project veritas one alleged ballot
harvester liban muhammad the brother of
minneapolis city council member jamal
osman
is shown in a bombshell snapchat video
rifling through piles of ballots strewn
across his dashboard
just today we got 300 for jamal osman
says muhammad
i have 300 ballots in my car right now
numbers don't lie you can see my car is
full
all these here are absentee ballots look
all these are for jamal osman he says
displaying the white envelopes
money is the king in this world and a
campaign is driven by money
the video was posted july 1st and was
obtained by project veritas and included
in a 17-minute video expose released on
sunday night
under minnesota law no individual can be
the designated agent for more than three
absentee voters so being the designated
agent for 300 absentee voters is a
problem
the allegations come just five weeks
before a presidential election plagued
with predictions of voter fraud both
trump and attorney general bill barr
have warned that the increased use of
mail-in ballots due to coven-19 concerns
about in-person voting
is vulnerable to fraud according to
james o'keefe our investigation into
this ballot harvesting ring demonstrates
clearly how these unscrupulous operators
exploit the elderly and immigrant
communities
the alleged involvement of omar is
claimed on camera by two people in the
veritas investigation including the
whistleblower omar jamal a minneapolis
community leader and chair
of the city's somali watchdog group he
claims muhammad is one of omar's many
people
he says in open secret she will do
anything she can to get elected she has
hundreds of people on the street
doing that meanwhile there's another
serious ballot issue
in new york apparently ballots have been
arriving receiving
mail-in ballots marked incorrectly again
according to the new york post voters in
new york city have received mail-in
ballots for the 2020 presidential
election
marked for military use despite never
having served in the armed forces
causing confusion and concerns over
whether the ballots can or should be
used
the misprint makes it appear that the
ballots received an official military
absentee ballot instead of a military
slash absentee ballot leaving several
borough residents who received the
documents including two post journalists
worried the votes might not be properly
tallied so a bunch of people could vote
and the votes could be not counted
all of this is mass confusion it is a
serious
problem in fact as i've said before
there are two real dangers when it comes
to the
massive mail-in voting that people are
pursuing right now
danger number one is that people fill
out the votes
wrong i mean it's actually a little more
complicated to fill in a mail on ballot
than it is to just go to the polling
place and do it that way
problem number two is ballot harvesting
if you have somebody who is going around
to only democratic households or to
unaffiliated households and telling them
how to vote
that gets really dangerous really
quickly you should have to go out to a
polling place and you should have to
vote unless you have some sort of
medical condition preventing you
from doing so and the prevalence of
kovid is not enough of a reason unless
you are elderly and specifically
vulnerable
if you are a 30 year old you should be
going to vote in person
there have not been outbreaks at voting
places and we have had several open
votes
since the beginning of the covet
outbreak to
proclaim that voter fraud is a serious
problem and that we should be concerned
about in a close election
that's not crazy that is something that
that is worthy of of
viewing and other sort of voting related
news there's now a
there's now a story that is being put
out there by channel 4
in the uk investigating the trump
campaign strategy
and i think it is worthy of note okay
the the trump campaign strategy in 2016
was designed to deter particular groups
from voting now this is not unusual
every campaign has targeted voters and
then voters that they wish to
not see show up at the polls right so
for democrats they don't wish to see
religious americans show up to the polls
in very big numbers because religious
americans show up in really big numbers
or non-college-educated white people
show up in really big numbers that's
very bad for the democrats
for republicans you look at various
communities and then you say okay which
communities are most likely to vote for
us and which communities are least
likely to vote for us
the media today are playing up the fact
that in 2016
the trump campaign using data analytics
saw that certain groups were likely not
to vote for them and certain groups were
likely to vote for them that they were
going to try and quote unquote depress
the vote that doesn't mean that they're
going to
lock people in their homes or they're
going to screw with the ballot or
anything like that
it means they're going to target ads at
people making them not really want to
vote
that's just called politics okay and
it's not specifically racially based if
black americans
voted for republicans at a very high
rate republicans would be eager to have
many of those people vote democrats are
very eager to have lots of black
americans vote for a very good reason
they want a lot of black americans to
vote for democrats
do you think that democrats are very
eager to have lots of white non-college
educated voters vote
do you think that they're going door to
door in very religious catholic
communities and telling them they need
to get out to vote today
probably not so the media have tried to
play this again as the trump is racist
thing as opposed to campaigns target
their most likely voters
and they try to get them out and then
they try to make it the people
who are not going to vote for them stay
home that is not like a giant shock
and the fact that people are treating it
as a giant shock is because they don't
know the first thing about politics and
or because they are being deliberately
dishonest
okay so we're going to be back here a
little bit later today we're going to
have two additional hours of content we
have a great radio show coming up for
you today senator cruz is going to be on
it we have megan kelly on it she's
launching a new podcast
a lot coming up plus we're gonna we're
gonna talk debate as the day progresses
so stick around for that also tonight
make sure that you tune in to daily wire
backstage
because we are going to be watching this
thing live this monstrosity live
i hope you enjoy it more than i
undoubtedly will but we'll be there
together we will soldier through it
together go become a member over at
daily wire
and remember to use that promo code
debate for 20 off otherwise we'll see
you here tomorrow for all of the recap
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
is turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clayton